I'm not the type of actor
that can like disappear into a role
because my way into a character is
always my personal connection to them
and to me every character that I play is
like a version of Melissa if I had been
born under these circumstances at this
time that is why
um you are authentic even when you're
sitting here talking you just seem to be
having a conversation with the audience
and Kelly yeah I
[Applause]
my it's named Barrera
yeah I would have done that yeah you can
I know but I always ask people how you
do it because I hate that's my biggest
pet peeve but I never knew it was my pet
peeve before this show yeah but it's
like
everybody tries to American not you I
just mean people trying to americanize
names to like make it in I'm like we're
a Melting Pot filled with many different
cultures like we can all say Melissa but
you're a musician you have good ear
that's why you can I find that well then
all you musicians you can do it yeah
like it's like I just it's not but I
think if we're trained from childhood to
like say Melissa is beautiful it sounds
beautiful it sounds lyrical yeah like I
love it it's like a beautiful Melody
next time
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody